[Musik]
die Ukraine ist nun seit Juni
offizieller beitragskandidat der
Europäischen Union und ich bin sicher
die meisten von euch erinnern sich ein
Schlagzeilen wie diese die Europäische
Union gewährt der Ukraine in einem
historischen Moment den Kandidatenstatus
alle oder zumindest viele von euch
werden auch diesen historischen Moment
in den Nachrichten mitverfolgt haben
die Flagge der Europäischen Union ist
also bereits im ukrainischen Parlament
aufgepflanzt und in gewisser Weise ist
das auch nicht überraschend sowohl aus
Sicht des politischen Zusammenhalts in
Europa als auch aus militärischer Sicht
hat die Ukraine mehr als genug getan um
sich den offiziellen Kandidatenstatus zu
verdienen schließlich kämpft sie als
westlich und freiheitlich gerichtetes
Land unermüdlich gegen eine Regime dass
dieser und das heißt unserer
Lebenshaltung so radikal entgegensteht
schließlich war es für Russland ein
wichtiger Grund die Ukraine anzugreifen
weil sie ja auch Teil der freiheitlich
demokratischen Wertegemeinschaft sein
will aber dahinter stehen auch
schlagkräftige wirtschaftliche Gründe
dazu später mehr zudem hat auch in der
europäischen Politik nach der russischen
Invasion ein Umdenken stattgefunden und
man scheint allgemein bereit den
Beitritt der Ukraine zu beschleunigen
was auch immer das aktuell genau heißen
mag aber schön dass Symbol ist viel wert
zum einen natürlich für die Ukraine
selbst denn die Beitrittsperspektive ist
sicherlich ein enormer Schub für die
Motivation unser Selbstvertrauen der
ukrainischen Soldaten und der gesamten
Bevölkerung zum anderen ist er aber auch
von symbolischen Wert für die EU denn
was würde es für ihr Selbstverständnis
bedeuten im Sinne der Werte für diese
steht wenn sie nicht zumindest in
Betracht Vögel die Ukraine in ihre
Reihen aufzunehmen doch ist der
Kandidatenstatus vielleicht mehr als
eine symbolische Geste hat die Ukraine
eine realistische Chance in den Club der
EU-Länder aufgenommen zu werden nun
sicher ist nur das bis dorthin noch
einen weiter weg auf die Ukraine wartet
kein einfacher Weg für Mitgliedschaft in
der Europäischen Union für die Ukraine
der legitime Wunsch der Union
beizutreten stellt eine große
Herausforderung für das Land da
andererseits den enormen Risiken und
Herausforderungen steht auf der anderen
Seite mit einer Ukraine als EU-Mitglied
ein gigantisches Potenzial gegenüber zum
einen was die Sicherheit und Stabilität
ganz Europas angeht als auch in punkto
Wirtschaft die Ukraine ist mit 40
Millionen zum großen Teil gut
ausgebildeten Menschen nicht nur ein
großer Produktions- und Absatzmarkt für
Ihr Unternehmen allen voran für die
deutschen und sie ist als Kornkammer
Europas nicht nur ein wichtig Faktor zur
Festigung der Versorgungssicherheit und
Preisstabilität bei Lebensmitteln nein
das flächenmäßig nach Russland
zweitgrößte Land Europas verfügt auch
über beträchtliche Reserven an Erdgas
deren Erschließung Russland mit seinen
Aggressionen bislang erfolgreich
verhindern konnte um den Kontinent
weiterhin Abhängigkeit von seinem
eigenen sibirischen Gas zu halten und
auch die aktuellen laufenden
Psychospielchen bezüglich russischer
Gaslieferungen in die eu-decken dabei
vom riesigen ökonomischen
Zukunftspotenzial der ukrainischen
erdgas-reserven sowie Gasspeicher und
Biogas als Wurzen für die Wirtschaft
Europas ab denn betrachtet man die
erdgas-reserven im asiatischen Teil
Russlands als außereuropäische
Lagerstätten politisch haben die Staaten
der EU ja sowieso keinerlei Zugriff auf
sie verfügt die Ukraine heute über die
zweitgrößten bekannten europäischen
Gasvorkommen ein gewaltiges Fund mit dem
sie in den Verhandlungen für die EU
Mitgliedschaft buchen kann denn falls
ein Land mit derart gewaltigen
Lagerstätten ein verlässliches Mitglied
der Gemeinschaft würde wären alle
Energie sorgen und preisängste der
europäischen Besucher wie auch Industrie
für sehr sehr lange Zeit gelöst mehr
noch den alten Kontinent könnte eine
regelrechte Bonanza eine Ära ungeahnte
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und Prosperität ins
Haus stehen mit dem er seine globalen
Konkurrenten hinter sich lassen könnte
nur mal zum Vergleich Ende 2019
enthielten die bis dahin erkundeten
ukrainischen Lagerstätten 1,09 Billionen
Kubikmeter Erdgas das ist eine Menge die
innerhalb Europas nur den bekannten
norwegischen Ressourcen von 1,53
Billionen Kubikmetern nachsteht und noch
wegen ist auch nicht Mitglied der EU
wohlgemerkt dies sind die unter den sehr
erschwerten politischen Bedingungen
erkundeten vorkommen eine ungehinderte
Exploration könnte also noch viel mehr
Gaszug Tage fördern also liebe
visualpolitik Zuschauer welche
Hindernisse muss die Ukraine auf ihrem
Weg in die EU überwinden könnte sie es
wirklich schaffen Mitglied zu werden was
sind die wichtigsten Schritte des
dorthin all diese Fragen werden wir in
diesem Video beantworten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eines gleich vorne weg ein Beitritt zur
Europäischen Union ist kein Spaziergang
und auch komplizierter als zum Beispiel
ein Beitritt zur NATO um Teil der Union
zu werden müssen die Beitrittskandidaten
viele Vorschriften erfüllen und eine
Menge Änderungen in Rechtspolitik und
Wirtschaft vornehmen kroatien hat zum
Beispiel nicht weniger als zehn lange
Jahre gebraucht um Mitglied zu werden
natürlich ist dieser Zeitraum nicht
festgelegt es liegt an jedem Einzelnen
Land selbst wie lange es braucht um die
Voraussetzungen zu erfüllen Finnland
also ein Land das bereits über
demokratische Institutionen und ein
etablierte freie Marktwirtschaft
verfügte oder drei Jahre nach
Antragstellung aufgenommen aber keine
Frage die Ukraine ist Kroatien vor
seinem Aufnahmeprozess in die EU näher
als es Finnland war
[Musik]
besonderes auf zerbrechen beschert den
Beitrittskandidaten zum Beispiel auf der
Artikel 2 des EU-Vertrages die Werte auf
die sich die Union gründet sind die
Achtung der Menschenwürde Freiheit
Demokratie Gleichheit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und die Wahrung der
Menschenrechte einschließlich der Rechte
der Person die Minderheiten angehören
diese Werte sind allen Mitgliedstaaten
in einer Gesellschaft gemeinsam die sich
durch Pluralismus nicht Diskriminierung
Toleranz Gerechtigkeit Solidarität und
die Gleichheit von Frauen und Männern
auszeichnet Artikel 2 des Vertrags über
die Europäische Union schon hier stellt
sich also bereits die Frage ob die
Ukraine das alles einhält wo man ja
schon öfter erlebt hat dass die EU auch
einen ziemlichen Ermessensspielraum
walten lassen kann wenn sie nur will
enger wird es bei anderen
Voraussetzungen so hat es eine Gründe
warum die Ukraine des ärmste Land
Europas ist und sich im Vergleich zu
anderen ehemaligen Ostblock-Staaten
schlecht entwickelt hat ihr wisst alle
dass wir hier auf visualpolitik den
russischen Angriffskrieg scharf
verurteilen und solidarisch an der Seite
der Ukrainer stehen doch die Aktivität
gebietet es dieses Land auch nicht durch
die rosarote Brille zu betrachten heute
sind sowohl die Politik als auch die
Wirtschaft der Ukraine weit von
westlichen Standards entfernt
[Musik]
zum Beispiel greift der Staat stark in
die Wirtschaft ein es gibt
Preiskontrollen und eine Handvoll
milliardenschwerer Oligarchen
monopolisiert strategisches Sektoren der
nationalen Wirtschaft staatliche
Eingriffe und Preiskontrolle verhindern
eine akkurate Informationsvermittlung
auf den Märkten und erschweren so massiv
ein effektives Wirtschaften die Monopole
leben die Wirtschaft Hüllen die ohnehin
schwachen Institutionen aus und
unterlaufen allgemein die freiheitliche
Ordnung was wiederum neue staatliche
Eingriffe provoziert und Monopolbildung
begünstigt und so weiter und so fort
aber es kommt noch schlimmer jenen
Oligarchen sind viel zu gut mit den
politischen Betrieb vernetzt und werden
auf die ein oder andere Weise vom
politischen Apparat selbst protegiert
anstatt von ihm kontrolliert zu werden
auf diese Weise ergibt sich ein
hochgradig korruptes ziemlich
verkrustetes und schwer reformierbares
System was auch dadurch nicht besser
wird das Korruption nicht nur ganz oben
grassiert sondern in allen
administrativen und wirtschaftlichen
Schichten des Landes allgegenwärt laut
transparencil international ist die
Ukraine nach Russland das zweit
korrupteste Land in ganz Europa zwar
versuchte vor dem Krieg gerade Präsident
selenski die Korruption zumindest in
einigen Bereichen einzudämmen deswegen
wir ihm ja auch im letzten Jahr den
visualpolitik an Wort verliehen haben
aber bis heute kann man nicht wirklich
erkennen dass seine Bestrebungen eine
wirkliche Zeitenwende oder gar eine
Mentalitätswechsel herbeigeführt hätten
zwar hat man sich wegen des Krieges
nochmal zusammengerafft aber auch hier
gibt es massive Probleme ein Beispiel
sind die Berichte über den angeblichen
Diebstahl westlicher Waffenlieferungen
an das Land allerdings zeigen diese vor
allem dass die Dinge durchaus komplexer
sind und beim Thema Korruption
Pauschalurteile nur wenig weiterhelfen
so behauptet der US Fernsehsender CBS
das ein großer Teil der Militärhilfe
einfach verschwindet und zitierte hierzu
eine litauischen
hilfsorganisationsmitarbeiter
[Musik]
dieser sagte nur 30 Prozent der Waffen
erreichten ihren endgültigen
Bestimmungsort an der Front nun
präsentierte CBS jedoch keine weiteren
Beweise und der Ngoma selbst stellte
später klar dass seine Aussage aus dem
Kontext gerissen worden sei er wüsste
nichts von direkten
diebstahlschiebereien auf dem
Schwarzmarkt oder gar nicht verkauft der
Waffen einer Russland sondern hätte die
Verteilung der Militärhilfe unter dem
ukrainischen Einheiten selbst gemeint er
habe lediglich kritisieren wollen dass
bis April nur 30 bis 40 Prozent der
Lieferungen direkt an die Front gegangen
wären während der Rest an andere
Einheiten gingen oder aufgrund
logistischer Probleme oder politischer
Machtkämpfe nicht schnell genug bei den
Kampfverbänden angekommen sein der Grund
hierfür seinen Strukturen in denen
lokalfürsten selbstgerechte Bürokraten
Oligarchen und politische Akteure die
effiziente Verteilung der Waffen
behindern würden um z.B sich selbst oder
Einheiten in ihrer Region zu bevorzugen
kurz um Zank Eitelkeiten und inner
ukrainisches Konkurrenzdenken
Behinderten eine effiziente Distribution
der sitzen deswegen hat die Ukraine
mittlerweile eine Sonderkommission
eingerichtet um den waffenfluss
innerhalb des Landes genauso verfolgen
um die USA haben ihren
verteidigungssachter schebriker die
general garik m Harmon im August 2022
damit beauftragt die Kontrolle der
rüstungslogistik in der Ukraine auf
Vordermann zu bringen die Frage ist
allerdings wieso dies nicht schon lange
vorher geschehen war denn das ein Krieg
kommt der nur durch massive Waffenhilfe
aus dem Westen zu gewinnen ist war lange
klar und das massive Lieferungen so
kostbarer Güter wie Waffen eine
Gelegenheit darstellen die auch die
beschafft was jedes Schulkind
die Ukraine hat ja wie auch Russland
eine sehr lange Tradition massiven
Waffen Diebstahls und schließlich hatten
die USA selbst übelste Erfahrungen mit
schwerer Korruption und waffendiebstahl
wie zum Beispiel im Irakkrieg 2003 als
Dutzende von Milliarden Dollar einfach
versickerten und große waffenbestände
schließlich 2014 sogar an den Feind da
Ash fielen als dieser große Teile des
Landes Einnahmen in jüngster Zeit
konnten wir die gleiche Situation schon
wieder in Afghanistan erleben ein Thema
über das ein eigenes Video gedreht haben
es bleibt also nur zu hoffen dass die
USA und mit ihnen die Ukraine aus diesen
Desastern gelernt haben und nun die
entsprechenden Überwachungsmechanismen
stringent einführen denn im
Worst-Case-Szenario wenn die Ukraine den
Krieg verlieren sollte es stimmte in
Europa eine neue Grauzone des Schreckens
ein neuer fail state auf dessen Boden
sich eine gewaltige Menge hochgradig
tödlicher Waffen befindet oder gar in
die Hände der russenfeld allein dies ist
für Europa schon einen gewichtiger Grund
dafür dass die Ukraine den Krieg
gewinnen stabilisiert werden und dann
fest in die europäischen
Ordnungsstrukturen eingebunden werden
muss ja die Alternative dazu wäre
einfach nur einen grauen ohne Ende für
die Bevölkerung der Ukraine wie für die
ganz Europas denn im europäischen
Vergleich war die Ukraine bereits vor
dem Krieg bettelarm um euch eine
Vorstellung zu geben wir reden hier über
ein Land dessen pro Kopf bepia 2021
kommt 40% des Prokop BIPs Bulgariens
betrug dem derzeit ersten Land der EU
übrigens haben wir auch darüber schon
lange vor den Krieg 1 separates Video
gedreht dass ich euch verlinken werde
und natürlich ist es durch den Krieg
noch viel schlimmer geworden
schlussendlich muss die Ukraine
praktisch auf allen Gebieten Politik
Wirtschaft Recht und Gesellschaft und
verdammt viel Veränderungen vornehmen
einige Experten schätzen dass der
Beitritt wenn er denn endlich
stattfindet 10 bis 20 Jahre dauern
könnte eine schiere Ewigkeit aber wer
weiß sollte der Krieg nicht mit einem
Siegfrieden Russlands enden könnte das
die Gelegenheit sein um in der Ukraine
Reform mäßig klar Schiff zu machen
schließlich sind seitdem Kollaps das so
wird Union auch bereits 30 Jahre
vergangen europa muss in dieser Frage
also endlich grundsätzlich in
längerfristigen strategischen und
geostrategischen Dimensionen denken wenn
es in der Lage sein will mit den anderen
großen Weltregionen auch in Zukunft zu
konkurrieren und auch die größte
Wirtschaftsmacht Europas Deutschland
muss mit seinem kleinen aufhören endlich
den Realitäten dieser Welt und seiner
Verantwortung ins Auge blicken dass ich
so wie bisher ein sicheres stabile
prosperierendes Europa nicht aufbauen
und schon gar nicht erhalten lässt
klotzen ist angesagt nicht kleckern was
genau sind also die wichtigsten Reformen
die die Ukraine durchführen muss um
EU-Mitglied zu werden und was sind die
größten Hindernisse genau das nehmen wir
jetzt genau unter die Lupe
der lange Weg in die EU
wenn wir die Europäische Union
definieren müssten könnten wir das
vielleicht mit drei Worten tun
Bürokratie endlose Vorschriften und
komplexe Intransparenz ach ja und habe
ich eigentlich schon die lebende
Bürokratie erwähnt nun all das ist im
weiteres Prozess nicht anders ja
vielleicht sogar besonders schlimm hier
muss der Kandidat gleich von 0 auf 100
durchstarten und alle EU-Vorschriften
auf einmal etablieren der
Beitrittsprozess lässt sich in sechs
Phasen unterteilen vor meiner Antrag auf
Mitgliedschaft Kandidatenstatus
Heranführungshilfe Verhandlungen
Ratifizierung und schließlich die
Integration nach der Ratifizierung als
offizieller Kandidat ist die Ukraine nun
in die dritte Phase eingetreten die
heranführungsphase in dieser Phase muss
ich die Ukraine wie jedes andere
Kandidaten Land mit der Europäischen
Kommission auf eine sogenannte
Heranführungsstrategie einlegen diese
Strategie besteht darin eine Reihe von
Leitlinien für die Ukraine festzulegen
um die administrativen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Reformen in ihre
Rechtsprechung aufzunehmen die es
ermöglichen werden europäische Gesetze
umzusetzen
wir reden hier nicht von ein paar
kleinen Änderungen sondern von mehr als
130.000 Seiten europäischer Gesetzgebung
die die Ukraine nun in ihr politisches
und rechtliches System einführen muss
eine nicht nur verdammt anstrengender
und hochgradig komplexer sondern auch
ein ziemlich kostspieliger Prozess aber
niemand hat gesagt dass es einfach
werden dort und natürlich macht die
Wirtschaft da keine Ausnahme die Ukraine
wird ihr Wirtschaftsmodell in vieler
Hinsicht grundlegend ändern müssen denn
um der eu-beiträgen zu dürfen muss eine
funktionierende freie Marktwirtschaft
etabliert sein die sich ohne
Einschränkungen in den gemeinsamen Markt
integrieren kann und das ist viel
leichter gesagt als getan immerhin ist
die Ukraine ein Land das einmal zur
Sowjetunion gehört hat und bei der
Abschaffung des Sozialismus wenig besser
agiert als Russland selbst darüber haben
wir übrigens auch ein Video gemacht aber
dazu gleich mehr muss die Ukraine also
noch einmal bei Null anfangen nun ja das
hängt sicher auch davon ab wie sich der
Krieg weiterentwickelt aber
grundsätzlich hat die Ukraine in den
letzten haben wir schon einige Schritte
hin zum EU-Standard gemacht die Ukraine
hat sich schon seit den 90er Jahren
allmählich auf die EU zu bewegt seit
2016 ist die assoziiertes Mitglied womit
Sie bereits eine engere wirtschaftliche
Bindung an die EU einging darüber hinaus
wurde so auch der politische und
kulturelle Dialog institutionell
gestärkt seither wurden dann noch einige
Änderungen bereits durchgeführt das EU
Assoziierungsabkommen der Ukraine
verpflichtet Kiew zu rechtsstaatlichen
Reformen nach dem Zerfall der
Sowjetunion war die Ukraine durch das
Post sowjetische Handelsabkommen der
Gemeinschaft unabhängiger Staaten Gus
erstmal nach Osten ausgerichtet mitsamt
der entsprechenden Wirtschaftsformen
[Musik]
jedoch ist die Ukraine aufgrund ihrer
schieren Größe und in diversen
unterschieden zwischen Ost- und West
ziemlich in homogen aufgestellt in den
westlichen Provinzen bestand immer eine
Stärke Orientierung zu EU als in
Ortsteil dank des Assoziierungsabkommens
aber begann die gesamte ukrainische
Wirtschaft sich mit Vollgas Richtung
Westen zu bewegen das heißt weg von
Russland und der Gemeinschaft
unabhängiger Staaten in Richtung der EU
tatsächlich machte der Handel mit der EU
im Jahr 2020 bereits mehr als 40% alle
ukrainischen Exporte aus das ist 8 mal
mehr als die Exporte nach Russland ein
Prozess der sich mit Putins Invasion
natürlich keineswegs verlangsamt sondern
sogar noch beschleunigt hat
28 April 2022 EU will Zölle auf
ukrainische Importe für ein Jahr
aussetzen Kiew zeigt sich dankbar 29
Juni 2022 die Ukraine und die EU
unterzeichnen ein Abkommen zur
Liberalisierung des Straßenverkehrs mit
dem Abkommen entfällt für ukrainische
Transportunternehmen die Notwendigkeit
Genehmigungen für die die Preise in die
EU zu erhalten außerdem wurde das
ukrainische Strom letztendlich anders
europäische Netz angeschlossen
1 Juli 2022 selensky sagt die Ukraine
exportiere jetzt Strom in die EU tja und
die eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der
Leyen meinte kürzlich selbst dass die
Ukraine dank des Assoziierungsabkommens
bereits etwa 70% der europäischen
Gesetze und Grundsätze umgesetzt habe
neben vielen anderen Änderungen wurde
zum Beispiel das öffentliche
Beschaffungswesen verbessert zudem
wurden die amtliche Statistiken an
europäische Standards angenähert und der
Energiemarkt reformiert der zuvor
vollständig in staatlicher Hand lag die
Ukraine hat sogar eine digitale
Verwaltung entwickelt
[Musik]
aber mal halblang erinnert euch noch was
wir vorhin über die verkrusteten
Strukturen in der Ukraine gesagt haben
ich meine digitale Verwaltung neuer
Strommarkt und so weiter ist der schon
und gut aber 70 Prozent der nötigen
Reformen schon erfüllt das glaubt Frau
von allein und selbst kaum was sagt
diese quantitative Angabe überhaupt aus
nun es handelt sich wohl eher um eine
Zahl die nach dem Pareto-Prinzip
interpretiert werden muss 80 Prozent der
Ergebnisse erfordern nur 20% des
Gesamtaufwands aber die restlichen 20%
haben es in sich und erfordern dann 80%
des Aufwands und von der lines 70%
dürften wohl zu 100% in den leicht
umsetzbaren 80% liegen denn die Kluft
welche die Ukraine immer noch von
europäischen Standards trennt ist ganz
klar schlicht und einfach riesig hier
ein paar Beispiele und Kennzahlen
[Musik]
wie gesagt ist laut transparents
international die Ukraine des
zweitkorrupteste Land in Europa aber
damit nicht genug auf den Index
wirtschaftlicher Freiheit liegt die
Ukraine auf Platz 130 von 177 Ländern
und befindet sich damit in einer Liga
mit Ländern wie Uganda Indien und
Belarus im human freedomindex liegt die
Ukraine auf Platz 98 praktisch gleich
auf mit Burkina Faso Kasachstan und
Mosambik im rechtsstaatlichkeitsindex
der die Qualität der justizminist liegt
sie auf Platz 74 im Index der
Pressefreiheit auf Platz 106 und Index
der demokratischen Qualität auf Platz 6
und 80 im human development-index
übrigens mit einem Wert von 0,779 auf
Platz 74 ein guter Gesellschaft mit
Mexiko einem Land in dem setzt du
Friedenszeiten gemordet wird wie in
einer Kriegszone siehe auch unser Video
hierzu mit anderen Worten egal wie man
es dreht und wenn die Ukraine ist noch
weit vom EU-Beitritt entfernt allerdings
geht es nicht nur um die formale
Anwendung europ Vorschriften das würde
in der Ukraine nicht ausreichen
schließlich herrscht dort immer noch
Krieg welche konkreten Schritte sind
also nötig nun keine Angst wir haben uns
die Arbeit gemacht und liefern euch
jetzt die Roadmap dazu also aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine kolossale Herausforderung
nehmen wir doch mal so optimistisch wie
wir sind an der Krieg endet nicht mit
einem Siegfrieden Russlands selbst dann
ist der EU-Beitritt trotzdem nicht das
vordringlichste Problem der Ukraine
parallel müssen immerhin weite Teil des
Landes wieder aufgebaut die
Kriegswirtschaft auf Normalbetrieb
umgestellt monetäre Effekte ausgeglichen
überhaupt die ganze Wirtschaft wieder
auf die Beine gestellt werden es ist
offensichtlich das ist für ein Land das
physisch und institutionell zerstört ist
praktisch unmöglich wäre der
Europäischen Union beizutreten egal
welche Reformen es durchführt und um ein
Argument gleich vorweg vom Tisch zu
nehmen ein Beitritt der Ukraine noch
während des Krieges ist auf jeden Fall
ausgeschlossen denn dann könntet ihr
nach Artikel 42 Absatz 7 des EU-Vertrags
militärischen Beistand von anderen
EU-Staaten einfordern die EU wäre
offiziell Kriegspartei allerdings ist
davon auszugehen dass ein von Putin
regiert ist Russland die Ukraine nie in
Ruhe lassen wird auch wenn es nicht mehr
in der Lage sein sollte territorial
voranzukommen wird es sein Nachbarland
mit Gewalt und Zerstörung terrorisieren
wollen solange es nur geht dann könnte
es jedoch speziell für die Ukraine
Ausnahme von erwähnten beistandsartikel
geben eine Formalität die ist so gute EU
als auch dem geschundenen Land erlauben
würde gemeinsam voranzukommen und den
Blogger im Osten zu ignorieren wenn der
Krieg also auf diese Weise formell
vorbei wäre muss die ukrainische
Regierung nicht nur versuchen die
EU-Gesetze und die Forderungen aus
Brüssel zu erfüllen sie wird parallel
auch ihren physischen und
institutionellen Wiederaufbau schnell
vorantreiben müssen
[Musik]
nach Schätzungen der ukrainischen
Regierung werden allein für den
Wiederaufbau von Brücken grundlegender
Infrastruktur und Gebäuden zwischen 100
und 200 Milliarden Dollar benötigt und
wenn wir die Wiederherstellung der
wirtschaftlichen und produktiven
Struktur der Ukraine dazu zählen könnte
die gesamte Rechnung bei weit über 500
oder 600 Milliarden Dollar liegen einen
solchen Mittelbedarf kann Brüssel
natürlich nicht ignorieren wenn es einen
Kandidaten für den Beitritt zur EU in
Betracht zieht mit anderen Worten am
Ende des Tages werden die europäischen
Institutionen eine Art Marshallplan
umsetzen müssen um den Wiederaufbau zu
unterstützen falls man ernsthaft
beabsichtigt die Ukraine wirklich mit
ins Boot zu holen allerdings scheint der
Wille aktuell durchaus da zu sein die
Europäische Union wird eine Plattform
für den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
errichten die Plattform soll dazu dienen
den Investitionsbedarf zu ermitteln
Maßnahmen zu koordinieren und Ressourcen
zu kanalisieren so von der Leyen denn
selbst wenn die Ukraine nicht
EU-Mitglied werden sollte ist eine
Stabilisierung der Region im Sinne aller
Europäer und natürlich nur mit der
Gemeinschaft Hilfe beim Wiederaufbau
realistisch die Herausforderung dabei
besteht darin diesen Sanierungsplan
umzusetzen ohne dass das Geld vor allem
in den Taschen der Oligarchen landet die
die Wirtschaft des Landeseiten
Zusammenbruch des Sowjetunion
kontrollieren denn stellte die EU
einfach nur eine Menge Geld zur
Verfügung das dann im korrupten Summen
versickert würde das den
Beitrittsprozess natürlich massiv
verkomplizieren wenn nicht Gas
sabotieren Brüssel scheint aber
zuversichtlich des Kiew ein umfassendes
wirtschaftliche liberalisierungsprogramm
durchführen wird ist das jedoch wirklich
tut bleibt abzuwarten die Erfahrungen
aus anderen Ländern haben zumindest
gezeigt dass es bei so gewaltigen in
Kombination mit entsprechenden Druck
möglich ist sich mit der herrschenden
wirtschaftsmomentklatura zu arrangieren
nach dem Motto wenn ihr zumindest einen
großen Teil nach den Regeln des spielt
fällt am Ende auch genug für jeden
einzelnen von euch ab die Oligarchen
würden sich also ins eigene Fleisch
schneiden wenn sie sich stur stellen die
Frage ist vor allem wie sie sich dabei
untereinander einig werden Präsident
selensky hatte vor dem Krieg zum
Beispiel seinen Vorgänger im Amt und
Oleg petroporoschenko wegen
hochverratsvor Gericht gezerrt nach dem
russischen Angriff haben jedoch beide
eine Art Burgfrieden geschlossen damit
das Land geeint gegen den gemeinsamen
Feind steht in den ersten zwei Wochen in
denen die Gefahr am größten war und in
denen ein großer Teil des Parlaments und
der Regierung ausgeht geflohen waren
blieben die einstigen Streithähne
selenski und poroschenko demonstrativ in
der Hauptstadt und zogen am gleichen
Strang etwas womit weder Putin noch der
Rest der Welt gerechnet hatten und was
für einen enormen Boost der ukrainischen
widerstands- und Kampfmoral sorgte es
könnte aber gut sein dass nach dem Ende
des Krieges und dem Sieg über den
gemeinsamen Feind diese alten Fäden
wieder fortgesetzt werden dennoch ist
das nicht das Schwierigste was die
Ukraine auf dem Weg in die EU erwartet
das schwierigste ist dass die Ukraine
ihre gesamte Staatsverwaltung
grundlegend ändern muss wie wir bereits
gesagt haben müssen die
gemeinschaftsgesetze umgesetzt werden
aber das reicht nicht aus die Ukraine
muss auch der Korruptionen Ende setzen
und zum Beispiel ein neues Justizsystem
schaffen in dem wirklich Gewaltenteilung
herrscht und das effektiv vor kooption
schützt all das ist leichter gesagt als
getan es muss sich noch zeigen ob die
patriotische Begeisterung ausreichen
wird um die Oligarchen zu Verzicht zu
bewegen und dann sollten wir nicht
vergessen dass wir über ein Land
sprechen in den tausende Jahrmillionen
von Menschen geflohen vertrieben im
Krieg verstümmelt oder traumatisiert
worden sind oft auch junge Menschen
junge Menschen mit einer Ausbildung und
beruflichen Fähigkeiten bzw solche easy
gerade eigentlich hätten erwerben sollen
aber wegen des Krieges nicht können in
diese Menschen sollten aber die
Schlüsselrolle im Prozess des
wirtschaftlichen und institutionellen
Wiederaufbaus der Ukraine und ihrem Weg
zur EU spielen wie gut sie das können
wird sich noch zeigen unsere Lektionen
aus der Geschichte legen zwei Ausgänge
nahe eine Kriegsgeneration kann Weise
erfahren abgehärtet und motiviert aus
dem Kampf hervorgehen wie zum Beispiel
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg oder aber
auch gebrochen traumatisiert und
irrlichternd wie nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg ohne wenigstens die Rückkehr
der ins Ausland geflohenen wird ist für
die Ukraine auf jeden Fall sehr
schwierig werden den notwendigen
Wohlstand Produktivität und
Entwicklungsstand zu erreichen um in
absehbarer Zeit der EU beizutreten denn
gerade diese Rückkehrer können wichtige
Erfahrungen und Beziehungen mit in die
Heimat bringen und die Wirtschaft damit
näher an das Niveau im Westen
heranführen aber damit sie zurückkehren
gar investieren oder Unternehmen gründen
können braucht es vor allem drei Dinge
Vertrauen Rechtssicherheit und offene
Märkte nun der erste Punkt ist generell
die Grundlage allen Wirtschaftens der
Patriotismus könnte zumindest das
Vertrauen steigern vor dem Hintergrund
der Verunsicherung bezüglich der Zukunft
untersuche nach Verrätern könnte es aber
auch zu einer Vertrauenskrise kommen die
wie Sand im wirtschaftlichen Getriebe
wirkt bei den beiden anderen Punkten
Rechtssicherheit und Marktöffnung
schlagen einige zum Beispiel vor das
Modell der Sonderwirtschaftszonen in
Dubai zu übernehmen nie im Fall des
Dubai international financial center
das klingt jetzt vielleicht erstmal ein
bisschen weit hergeholt aber wartet ab
denn dort bilden britische Richter
andere Richter aus und sprechen recht
gemäß ein speziellen rechtlichen Rahmens
die gesetzlichen Eckpfeiler sind dort so
gesetzt dass es für ausländische
Unternehmen besonders attraktiv ist dort
zu investieren aber ist ein solches
Szenario überhaupt realistisch für die
Ukraine nun in der Vergangenheit
sicherlich nicht aber auch hier hat es
ausgerechnet Wladimir Putin geschafft
zur vor unverrückbare Berge gewaltig in
Bewegung zu setzen und zwar ganz und gar
nicht in seinem eigenen Sinne die
ukrainische Oligarchie war vor dem Krieg
hauptsächlich in einen pro russischen
und einen westlichen Ast geteilt und
Lästerer auch noch untereinander
aufgespalten nun hat der russische
Vernichtungskrieg aber nicht nur die
prowestlichen Oligarchen Geheimzahlen
diese auch mit den zuvor pro russischen
es war petroporoschenko der als einer
der ersten der Nachricht die Ukraine in
ein Paradies für Investitionen zu
verwandeln und die Wirtschaft und die
Schaffung eines Systems mit weniger
Einschränkungen und Behinderungen für
ukrainische Unternehmen und Investoren
zu stärken aber nun scheint ein solches
Projekt auch einen anderen richtigen
Unterstützer gefunden zu haben den
Oligarchen Renate ach Mittwoch ist der
reichste Mann der Ukraine und im übrigen
der Besitzer des bekannten Stahlwerks
asastal in Mario Polt er ist dabei ein
Geschäftsmann der schon lange enge
Verbindungen zu Russland und den
russischen milieusen ukrainischen
Politik pflegte tatsächlich war er
sowohl grau Eminenz als auch
Hauptfinanzier der Rohstoff vielen
Partei der Regionen mit der sogar
Abgeordneten in der werkhofner Radar den
Parlament der Ukraine wurde klingt also
nicht gerade nach einem retten im Kampf
für die Freiheit und Unabhängigkeit der
Ukraine von Moskau nicht wahr aber jetzt
hört euch mal diese Aussage von ihm an
das Böse darf nicht ungestraft bleiben
Russlands Verbrechen gegen die Ukraine
und unser Volk sind ungeheuerlich und
die Schuldigen müssen zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden diese Klage ist einer der
ersten internationalen rechtlichen
Schritte gegen Russland um die
anhaltenden Verbrechen die Zerstörung
der ukrainischen Wirtschaft und die
Plünderung des ukrainischen Vermögens zu
stoppen erinnert Achmed auf ukrainischer
ome tja ob nun wegen des schnöden
Mammons der Zukunft der Ukraine oder der
plötzlichen Liebe zu seinem Vaterland
vielleicht auch wegen allem zugleich
direktbeginn radikal verändert
[Musik]
und wie er haben auch viele andere
pro-russische Oligarchen durch die
russische Invasion Verluste in
Millionenhöhe erlitten achmeetos
Vermögen ist doch Forbes Daten von
seinem Höchststand von 16 Milliarden
US-Dollar im Jahr 2012 auf etwa 4,2
Milliarden Dollar geschrumpft und das
ist ein Verlust von knapp 75%. doch so
widersprüchlich ist auch erscheinen mag
diese Situation könnte eine positive
Seite haben viele der großen
ukrainischen Oligarchen egal ob pro
westlich oder pro russisch mussten mit
ansehen wie ein großer Teil ihres
produktiven Vermögens von Russland
vernichtet wurde und damit auch ein
großer Teil ihrer Möglichkeiten Einfluss
auf die lokale und nationale Politik zu
nehmen mit anderen Worten die Zerstörung
eines Großteils ihres Reichtums und
ihres Einflusses sowie die
internationale Unterstützung und die
veränderten Prioritäten Kiews könnten
diese Oligarchen dazu bringen Änderungen
der Spielregeln zu akzeptieren um in
einem wirklich wettbewerbsorientierten
marktunternehmere stetig zu werden dazu
kommt dann noch dass der Wiederaufbau
und das soziale Druck und jetzt auch die
nationale Sicherheit viel gewichtträger
sind als die Bestechungsgelder und der
Druck dieser Oligarchen Oligarchen die
außerdem nicht weiter im Verdacht stehen
dürfen pro russische Sympatien zu
hegenskis Regierung verfügt nun auch
über die Rückendeckung der Opposition
das gesamte politische administrative
und ökonomische System der Ukraine von
Moskau affinen Kollaborateuren und
Sympathisanten zu säubern und hat aus
diesem Grund bereits zahlreiche
Spitzenbeamte entlassen es wäre also
wenig verwunderlich wenn in dieser
Situation nicht einige oder vielleicht
sogar alle mächtigen in der Ukraine nun
plötzlich ihr Fähnlein in den Wind
hängten und die Flagge der eu-histen das
heißt für Reformen eintreten würden so
könnte der Krieg zuletzt trotz aller
Schrecken wenigstens etwas Gutes haben
er könnte die Gelegenheit sein alte
verkrustete Strukturen hinter sich zu
lassen und neu anzufangen
zusammenfassen um ein vollwertiges
Mitglied der Europäischen Union zu
werden muss die Ukraine eine vorzeigbare
Demokratie mit digitalem Rechtsstaat
werden sie muss eine freie
Marktwirtschaft einführen sie muss die
sehr umfangreichen europäischen
Rechtsvorschriften in ihr Recht
einführen und dann anwenden Institution
reformieren und stärken das Land wieder
aufbauen und die Macht der Oligarchen in
geordnete Bahnen führen eine sehr lange
und sehr sehr komplizierte To-Do-Liste
aber wartet noch einen Moment in der
Beitritt zur EU hängt natürlich nicht
nur von der Ukraine ab sondern auch von
der EU sprich von ihren Mitgliedsländern
und um ein so großes und unruhiges Land
als Vollmitglied aufzunehmen musste ich
vielleicht auch die EU selbst ändern da
wären zum Beispiel die
Einstimmigkeitsregel die inzwischen
sogar der deutsche Bundeskanzler Scholz
ins Visier genommen hat zu oft ist die
Gemeinschaft gelähmt weil einzelne
Staaten ihren eigennützigen Willen
durchsetzen wollen denn widersprichwort
sagt starten haben keine Freunde Staaten
haben Interessen und wenn dieses
Phänomen jetzt schon zu oft in der EU
auftritt wie soll es erst werden wenn
die Union noch weiter wächst
zumal wenn man die erheblichen
Unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen
Mitgliedern bedenkt sowohl
wirtschaftlich also auch politische und
kulturell speziell die Ukraine wäre ein
enger Verbündeter Polens mit dem man wir
wissen in Brüssel schon lange Zeit seine
spezielle Freude hatte vielleicht sollte
man sich auch grundsätzlich Gedanken
darüber machen ob eine immer weiter
zunehmende Zentralisierung der EU
überhaupt noch Sinn ergibt und sowohl
dem ursprünglichen Geist der
Subsidiarität als auch einer zukünftigen
Vision der Gemeinschaft entspricht
sowohl die Bürokraten in Brüssel als
auch die Parlamente und Regierung der
einzelnen Mitgliedsländer ja alle
Europäer sollten sich mal ganz dringend
die Frage stellen was sie eigentlich
wollen ein auf kontinentale Größe
aufgeblähtes Frankreich oder einen
stärker dezentralisierten Verbund im
Stile einer großen Schweiz ich denke ihr
könnt euch vorstellen dass vor einem
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine diese
Grundsatzfrage geklärt werden sollte und
er wenn er denn jemals stattfindet ein
sehr langer und schwieriger Prozess sein
wird dann viele Bedingungen geknüpft ist
aber was meint ihr ist der angesichts
der eingangs erwähnten gewaltigen
wirtschaftlichen Chancen Europas in der
Ukraine nicht dennoch lohnenswert glaubt
ihr dass die Ukraine irgendwann der EU
wirklich beitreten kann und wird es Kiew
gelingen alle notwendigen politischen
und wirtschaftlichen Reformen
durchzuführen um die Ukraine zu einem
Land zu machen dass sich in die
gemeinschaftsstandards der übrigen
EU-Mitglieder einordnen kann wäre dies
im Interesse Europas oder eher nicht wie
immer sind auf eure angeregte Diskussion
zu diesem kontroversen Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt es bitte ein Like das mit euren
Freunden und vergesst nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich von uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den PayPal Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]